today we're gonna be trying therapy for
the very first time I think there was a
stigma in my family growing up about
therapy like oh other families might
have to deal with that but not Harr's
pacifically being black it's something
that we just don't talk about I think
gay men in particular we automatically
have a lot of baggage as men were
trained to bottle up or emotions I'm a
bottler I hate that about myself I think
mental health is just like your physical
health it's something that you need to
be working on all the time or else you
know you lose it because even someone
that you see on a regular basis who
looks like their life is perfect
sometimes they are the ones who are
hurting the most I've seen depression
affects a lot of people in my life I
want to know what I can do not just to
help myself but to help other people in
my life everyone goes through [ __ ] I
think it's important to get that out all
right let's go see the stranger
[Music]
hi Ryan I'm really excited to have you
here today thank you to bring some
awareness to like what's it like you
know going into therapy for the first
time like especially as a game in a
little bit about me and my background is
I finished my graduate degree from
Antioch University it's one of the first
degrees to offer an LGBTQ specialization
but enough about me I want to hear a
little about you I in Kansas City
Missouri I didn't come out until later
in life
my mom's super loving and then she
blamed herself which was weird
she was like because I wanted a daughter
really bad that part was hard to have
her feel some type of guilt I think what
you're picking up on though we have to
validate that right because we can pick
up on these like unspoken messages right
yeah families have to go through a
coming-out experience as well mourning
the death of this heterosexual child
that they imagined having and all the
fantasies that come along with that
right I'm extremely lucky I remember I
went for a walk with my dad who I told
him at dinner and my dad said I'm just
disappointed he didn't tell me sooner ah
and I was like really sweet my family
loves me so much and they give me so
much strength it's unfair because I know
like a lot of my own friends we've grown
up at houses and with parents that have
essentially disowned them but it's kind
of beautiful too because they go out and
they have to make their own families
absolutely I mean that's a huge
empowerment piece is being able to
create a family of choice right because
family of origin can't always be
everything I've been so conditioned to
be strong and to be this person who like
I almost don't have feelings so that's
something that is pretty standard in
black communities we just don't talk
about feelings which is an experience
that
and have this difficulty connecting with
our emotions the root problem of this
especially with men is that when we feel
emotions we fight against them all
emotions serve a purpose you know it's
just because it can feel so intense and
scary a lot of people don't want to deal
with that like a roller coaster ride you
know you're waiting in line you're gonna
get on it you feel the butterflies in
your stomach you see all the loops and
flips and everything looks really crazy
and then you get on the ride and yeah
it's intense but usually when you finish
it he's like oh okay I did that and I
could probably do it again with my
family I don't think we've ever talked
about mental health like not until I was
older I think I just kind of like found
out like with my brother he has moments
when he suffers from depression and it
was just something that we never talked
about and it didn't come up in the
household sometimes it's really easy to
distract but over time when we tend to
not deal with something it find ways to
come out I know a lot of people in my
life that had depression and mental
illness and I always don't know what to
do I think most importantly the
forefront is to let them know that
you're aware that this is what they're
going through but also to being mindful
what effect is is having on me too
because it's really easy of course when
you're we're talking about people whom
we love and we are very close with to
get pulled in it's like on an airplane
when they say you have to put the oxygen
mask on yourself before you can help the
person next to you it's almost a cliche
at this point the idea of it gets better
at least for me it's true it gets better
and better and better coming out was the
first step for me it was stepping onto
the roller coaster it was a little scary
but at the end I was so much happier and
so much better and I'm so happy that I
made that first step and I got on the
roller coaster
[Music]